the man at the center of the case is a  24 year old from stuttgart  his lawyers say he has made a full  confession  and hopes to put his islamist past  behind him  prosecutors say he traveled to syria in  summer 2013 where he joined islamic  state  he later returned to germany to buy  equipment for the group  helped by his brother and a friend  this is  this case shows us that the syrian  conflict is not confined to that country  it affects us here in germany too people  are being recruited here  in total some 40 germans are currently  under investigation over suspected links  to is  the most prominent is dennis cuspet  a former rapper he is thought to belong  to the group's inner circle  a jihadist video has surfaced showing  him present at murders by is fighters  prosecutors believe the man on trial in  stuttgart committed much lesser crimes  they say he became involved in militant  circles during a personal crisis after  the death of his child and a divorce  you